und dann nach dem mittagessen hat meine
mutter uns beide
meine nächste jüngeren bruder und mich
zu sich geholt und hat uns gesagt also
das attentat auf den führer
das war das papier
[Musik]
stichwort zeitreise fahren wir
vielleicht mal an mit dem 15 16 17
die so ein paar tage vor dem 20 juli
1944 wo waren sie daran können sie sich
erinnern
also ich kann ihnen die tage jetzt nicht
mehr so genau sagen aber alle anfang
juli war die schule in bamberg zu ende
und ich habe da die aufnahmeprüfung ins
gymnasium abgelegt und danach sind wir
zu meiner anderen großmutter
väterlicherseits auf die schwäbische alb
gereist und da war eben dann einige tage
später ich kann sie nicht genau sagen
wie viele plötzlich die nachricht im
radio
im einzigen was damals in dem großen
anwesen war das ein attentat auf den
führer folgt worden sein
ja und dann nach dem mittagessen hat
meine mutter uns beide
meine nächste jüngeren bruder und mich
zu sich geholt und hat uns gesagt also
das attentat auf den führer
das war ein papier was du dich ein
riesenschock für uns war das sofort in
haltloses weinen ausgebrochen und ich
habe gefragt ja wie kann man jemanden
den führer umbringen wollen
da hat meine mutter gesagt er wollte es
für deutschland tun
sie wollten für sie was ein schock als
sie gehört haben dass ihr vater dieses
attentat verübt hat wie war denn ihre
ganze einstellung zum hitler und zu dem
krieg zu tun
die war so wie wir damals alle waren wir
werden auch jan aufgewachsen sind es
dafür eben der führer ist und der das da
die höchste autorität ist und wie sehr
schöne spruch in dem lied führer befiehl
wir folgen dir das hat man einfach
akzeptiert ja und
da war es mit 10 musste man ja das war
pflicht
das deutsche jung volk wie das hieß das
war sie waren die kleinen bei der
hitlerjugend eintreten
ich war drei tage zu jung ja stichtagen
war der 30 juni und juli geboren und ich
wollte mich freiwillig melden was ging
das war meine mutter sabotiert der
gesagt ja das ist so schnell gewachsen
und auf das gut für die gesundheit gut
ist und so also wir lassen denn dr
schuster dass unser arzt entscheiden
na ja der war natürlich geimpft und hat
sich dagegen ausgesprochen
aber die masse meiner klasse waren als
für die jungen volk dann wüssten sie was
die nazis mit ihnen vor
gab es da einen plan wie wein das war
natürlich die große ungewissheit was
passiert wenn du das eigentlich
wir wussten ja nicht mal was mit unseren
familien passiert waren meine mutter zu
sichern und 23 juli 44 und was man sich
der dort im juli 45 ja nicht mehr
gesehen
[Musik]
wenn man der abend im bett liegt alleine
und an seine mutter denkt was was kommen
andere gedanken drüber
das waren natürlich gedanken waren beim
einschlafen also hat er noch ich kann
nicht sagen dass ich noch an den sieg
geglaubt habe aber so sicher war ich mir
auch nicht noch nie wieder krieg
ausgehen würde also bevor wir verhaftet
wurden dabei also die geschichte mit den
vergeltungswaffe den v waffen ja woran
sie propaganda große zuversicht zu
vermitteln versucht hat aber ich weiß
mein vater das letzte mal auf besuch war
im juni anfang juni 44
da passierte die alliierten landung in
der normandie
ich erinnere mich dass ich mein vater
die zeitung gezeigt habe und wollte
wissen was das bedeutet dass da nichts
sondern schultern gezuckt glaube ich so
obwohl sie nicht dazu äußern
jetzt sind sie doch mal von der zeit war
sie ihres persönlichen kriegsendes davor
nun ja also wir sollten ja klappen wird
also was ostermontag
sollten wir und wohin kommen wohin wurde
nicht gesagt aber es ist wohl klar dass
es buchen weil sein sollte das kz
buchenwald wo die erwachsenen bei der
familie oder unserer familiären die da
waren aber durch meine mutter war
für eine zeit lang und wir sollten also
dann wurden nach nordhausen gebracht
werden
und wie wir dort hausen noch rein kam
ging ein väterlicher bombenangriff los
und wir stand nur durch seinen
beeindruckenden baum werkstattwagen ja
so einen kastenwagen mit fenstern warfen
sie dann muss man sagen wer zuerst haben
wir gesagt das ist schwere flac die da
knallt aber das war ja und wir lagen
darin am boden manchmal ein bisschen
rausgeschaut ja das ist vorbei war
ob die wussten dass ja kein zug mehr am
bahnhof gehen würde oder vermutet haben
jedenfalls wurde die vater abgebrochen
und wir sind wieder zurück nach bad
sachsa in das heim noch einen umweg über
stolberg im harz und so aber abends war
dann was sagst du
und da blieb mir dann das leben da
weiter und ja dann kam der amerikaner
und wenn sie ihren vater heute
betrachten sehen sie ihn als vorbild ja
fragt sich natürlich was hätte außerdem
werden können ja 36 ja kein alter was
würden sie ihren vater gerne fragen wenn
sie ihn etwas fragen könnten nach gott
auf diese frage hatte sich vorher
vorbereiten dürfen also eine frage
natürlich
der habe ich schon weiter beantwortet
ist warum hat er die zweite sprengladung
aus der tasche genommen
meine antwort ist er wusste nicht dass
sie mit hochgehen würde ohne zünder
aber die erde vielleicht gerade in
unterschied gemacht
wie beurteilen sie denn die die heutige
zeit viele sagen ja dass unsere
gesellschaft sich gerade wieder in eine
gefährliche richtung bewegt
also ich glaube dass das etwas
übertrieben ist aber eine eine gewisse
gefahr dass lehren vergessen werden
besteht natürlich die leute die sich
nicht mehr erinnern können weil sie nie
erlebt haben ja dass wir meinen dinge
wieder neu zu entdecken auf zu werben
die bisher schon nicht persönlich
persönlich glaube es geht uns einfach zu
gut
wir können uns jetzt solche faxen
leisten
aber wer weiß noch wie es ist wenn es
ein wirklich schlecht geht
sie können doch nicht mehr vorstellen
sie können sich nicht mehr vorstellen
dass sie nicht keinen urlaub mehr haben
zu dem sie auch noch ins ausland fahren
können dass sie dort alles kaufen können
was wir wollen ja richtig not ist nicht
mehr vorstellbar wo dann alle zusammen
helfen das
er war sehr schön dann machen wir mal
die mikros augen